the keys to prosperity and
competitiveness in the twenty-first
century our innovation entrepreneurship
and brainpower and so I think we need to
be doing things now that foster those
and as well I think we need to be
choosing policies now that don't just
bring some relief in the short term but
help us create jobs here at home and
grow our economy over the longer term as
well if you assume as I do that
innovation is the cornerstone of 21st
century competitiveness then I think at
a macro level as a nation we need to
plan to lead in those industries that
will foster the most innovation for
example those industries include energy
healthcare space technology information
technology and if we're going to lead in
those industries government can
certainly play a role by investing it's
federally funded rd into those areas the
private sector can play a role and
government can encourage more private
sector rd through its tax policies or
tax credits and we need to make sure
that when we retrain workers that we are
giving them the skills so that they can
compete for jobs in the energy sector
for example for example green technology
or nuclear technology and we need to be
giving children tools like mathematics
science the ability to be
entrepreneurial and innovative as they
grow into their adult years
we should be retraining workers so that
they can move for example from the
automotive industry into the energy
industry we know that we must achieve a
higher degree of energy independence we
know that that will mean nuclear power
clean green technologies
battery-operated cars we should be
making sure that we are retraining
workers said that they can go from for
example a production line at General
Motors that's building the gas guzzler
that probably won't be sold very much in
the future to perhaps working on new
technologies and potentially in new
industries
well I think America has to first
embrace the changing realities of the
21st century it is a global economy we
can try and hide from that but we cannot
stop the globalization process we can
absolutely continue to compete and lead
and in order to continue to compete and
lead we must focus very much on the
things that have always made us strong
we have always been the most innovative
country in the world we must continue to
be we have always been the place in the
world where entrepreneurial new ideas
spring we must continue to be we have
always been the nation with the
hardest-working most productive
employees in the world we must continue
to be and we must always be the nation
with the smartest people and the best
educated people in the world and that's
why we need to invest in innovation and
entrepreneurship and job creation and in
education and training
it is worthwhile for the new
administration to spend some time with
Capitol Hill coming up with broad
agreements about what are our priorities
what are our goals what are our agendas
before we dive right into specific
policies